what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and it
is now officially confirmed adam warlock
is heading to the mcu in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3. the teaser at the end
of guardians of the galaxy vol 2 was
placed there for a very specific reason
i know a lot of people were worried that
because of everything that had happened
with guardians of the galaxy vol 3 the
firing and rehiring of james gunn him
going on to directing the suicide squad
and a few script rewrites a lot of
people were worried that we weren't
going to be seeing adam warlock but lo
and behold james gunn has come out and
confirmed to us that adam warlock will
indeed be in guardians 3. and of course
i will break it all down in this video
and if you're new to the channel and you
love marvel and want to stay up to date
on all things happening in the mcu
consider subscribing and hitting that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so like i
said a couple of days ago i posted a
video stating that it looks like we
could have already had our adam warlock
been cast actually a couple of years ago
there was a report from the
cosmiccircus.com
stating that they had heard from some
sources that the actor will poulter
could have been cast as adam warlock for
guardians of the galaxy vol 3. now at
the time it was just a rumor but what's
actually really funny is that even in my
video i stated that james gunn usually
comes out and confirms or denies these
rumors james gunn is very active on
social media and anytime anybody reports
something that's not true he is usually
there to shut it down or confirm it he's
came out and he's confirmed that yeah a
couple of people are going to die in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 coming
straight from him on twitter and the
same thing has just happened like i
mentioned a lot of people were talking
about this rumor and report and james
gunn saw it and of course he has now
addressed it deadline hollywood posted
on twitter guardians of the galaxy vol 3
will poulter to play adam warlock in the
next installment of the marvel franchise
in which james gunn quote tweeted them
stating as you guys know i often strike
down false rumors so um
welcome to the guardians family will
poulter he's an amazing actor and
wonderful guy see you in a couple weeks
hashtag adam warlock hashtag guardians
of the galaxy vol 3. so there you have
it will poulter is officially adam
warlock now i've posted on twitter and
i've posted on instagram and if you're
not following me on there you should but
i've seen what everybody has to say
about this casting rumor which is now
obviously confirmed and i know a lot of
people are like really this guy the you
guys are getting paid guys the we're the
millers guy and if you're judging him
just based off of that movie i get it
but the truth is he's actually been in
some pretty good things if you watch the
revenant with leonardo dicaprio you'll
see some amazing acting from him he was
also in the chronicles of narnia and the
maze runner and honestly i've seen some
pictures out there now of him where i
think that he actually can really pull
this off obviously he's going to have to
bulk up but i think a lot of people
still picture him as a very young skinny
man when in reality he's not anymore
he's in his late 20s and could have very
well put on some muscle since we last
saw him and there's still of course time
to put on some muscle now james gunn
also here confirmed that they're going
to start shooting in a couple of weeks
which means we could be getting some
pictures of him as adam warlock in a
couple of weeks perhaps he might tease
the role perhaps james gunn might tease
the role marvel studios might do it or
perhaps we'll get some leaked photos
that normally happen and again i
actually think that it is good that he's
a younger guy because that means that
marvel studios wants adam warlock to be
around in the mcu for a decent amount of
time they want to spend some time with
this character and this is essentially
going to be an origin story of adam
warlock now i have full trust in james
gunn and kevin feige in their casting
choices they've done a phenomenal job so
far so i'm not really that worried about
this i think he'll do a great job
playing the character i think they'll
take him in a really really good
direction and i'm really really excited
to see him on screen but let me know
what you guys think about this in the
comments down below what do you think of
will poulter playing adam warlock as it
is now officially confirmed don't forget
to like the video and follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof